know you're a big steven spielberg fan
we haven't heard from steven in a while
do you want to see if we can get him on
the phone and maybe he can talk to
caitlin hello oh hi stephen it's just
meg
this is max again how you doing over
there well we've got caitlin in the
studio we were just wondering caitlyn
olsen yes katelyn olsen the one and only
my god hello mr spielberg hi is this
kaitlyn yeah i have tried to get you in
so many of my movies and you just never
failed i i haven't heard a thing about
this this is the first time hearing of
this oh well who are you going i can say
this sometimes we will get
calls checking a veil what while we're
shooting well we never really know when
we're gonna shoot the season so we try
to just say you're not available yeah
that's not fair you guys are always
working uh i know yes because we don't
know when we're right yes we're we have
to so you say i'm not available yes
because we need to be available
to steven spielberg yeah well he's got
other options you guys suck